When there are decades of comic book history
to pull from for a superhero blockbuster,
it's impossible to adapt all the fan-favorite
moments and characters.
But that doesn't stop the directors, writers,
stars and crew from filling the movies with
details and jokes that the average fan might
miss out on - but not anymore.
If you’re a fan of our Hidden Details In
movies series, stick around until the end
for links to our other great videos!
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Amazing Hidden Details
In Movies SUPERHERO EDITION.
The Amazing Spider-Man 2
When Peter Parker finally decides to find
out what his father was up to before he disappeared,
all the clues point towards a single word:
Roosevelt.
One possible answer Peter comes across is
the Roosevelt Island Tramway.
In the original Spider-Man movie, Green Goblin
made Peter choose between saving Mary Jane
and one of that exact tramway's cars.
Fans may be torn on which version of Spider-Man
was best, but it's nice to see the reboot
give the original a nod.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
In the world of all time greatest movie pairings,
Paul Newman and Robert Redford are at the
top of the list.
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid made them
massive stars, and The Sting led them to the
top of the box office.
The pair would remain lifelong friends until
Newman's death in 2008, ending the hopes that
they'd share the screen one more time.
But when Redford landed the part of the villain
in Captain America: The Winter Soldier, the
crew made sure to honor his famous partner.
When Redford's character is seen getting a
carton of milk from his refrigerator, Newman
makes a cameo, with a bottle of the late actor's
"Newman's Own" marinara sauce making sure
that Butch and Sundance ride again (even if
it's just for a second).
Man of Steel
Most of General Zod's soldiers are left to
the background, without names or lines.
But it's hard to miss the oversized Kryptonian
that eventually teams up with Faora to beat
Superman to a pulp.
But his name, or how he became a giant is
never explained - unless you know your comic
Kryptonians.
The soldier is Nam-Ek, who in the comics tried
to unlock the healing powers of the Rondor,
a Kryptonian animal with horns that healed
all sickness.
When he tested his results on himself, he
became a massive, super-strong monster.
The same story is secretly at work here - but
you CAN catch a glimpse of the Rondor grazing
outside Jor-El's citadel.
Thor: The Dark World
When the action is over, Thor's girlfriend
Jane Foster is left waiting, not knowing when
the hero will return to Earth.
She only had to wait until the end of the
credits, when the two share a passionate kiss
- a more passionate kiss than fans have ever
seen.
That's probably because... it's not Natalie
Portman kissing him.
When it came time to film the scene, Chris
Hemsworth was available, but Portman wasn't.
Luckily, Hemsworth's wife, Fast & Furious
actress Elsa Pataky was travelling with him.
With her profile close enough to work, she
threw on the wardrobe and a wig, and the couple
gave audiences a kiss that could never be
faked.
The Dark Knight
In the world of Hollywood action movies, a
ticking clock or timer is usually pretty useless,
with minutes or seconds passing as slowly
or quickly as the movie demands.
So when Batman decides he only needs two minutes
and thirty seconds to steal a Gotham criminal
out of a Hong Kong skyscraper, audiences knew
it was a random number.
Or was it?
Bruce Wayne is nothing but punctual, since
he infiltrates the building, grabs his target,
and waits for the explosives to open his exit
- two and a half minutes later, almost to
the second.
We wish every comic book movie was as easy
to trust.
The Wolverine
Marvel fans know to keep an eye peeled for
a cameo from comics legend Stan Lee in almost
every film starring even one of his characters.
But when Wolverine broke off from his X-Men
colleagues for a standalone adventure in Japan,
a cameo gag didn't quite fit with the serious
tone.
The Wolverine doesn't feature a Lee appearance,
but when Logan is found living in the wild
with only a few items to his name, one of
them is a bottle of "Stanley's Whiskey".
Still a clear nod to the Marvel Comics creator.
Avengers Age of Ultron
Aside from giving Marvel's biggest heroes
a chance a supervillain to fight, the age
of Ultron also introduced fans to the African
nation of Wakanda - and a potential villain
for its hero, Black Panther.
Apparently the effects team was doing some
homework of their own.
When Bruce Banner investigates Klaw's brand,
the text on screen is actually the first two
paragraphs of the Wikipedia page on the fictional
country's history.
That means Banner learned the current "Black
Panther" is T'Challa before the rest of the
team even knew the hero existed.
Ant-Man
It isn't just fame or fun that convinces some
actors to take a superhero role, but a chance
to make a movie their kids can actually watch.
With Ant-Man, star Paul Rudd gave them much,
much more.
When the ex-con gets out of prison, he can
only find work at a Baskin Robbins, using
the fake name "Jack", and working with someone
named Darby.
They weren't random choices: those are the
names of Rudd's two children, making a cameo
in the movie... in name only.
Iron Man
When director Jon Favreau brought Iron Man
to the movie world, he brought Pepper Potts,
Happy Hogan and more Marvel characters along
with him.
But one didn't make the cut: Bambi Arbogast,
Tony Stark's trusty and sometimes overbearing
secretary.
Since the movie's Tony didn't spend much time
in the office, Bambi wasn't needed.
But Favreau and Robert Downey, Jr. didn't
forget her, making a brief reference in Iron
Man 2, and in Iron Man 3, confirming that
she does exist in the movie universe - just
slightly off screen.
X-Men: Days of Future Past
Mystique might have kicked off the terrible
future of this X-Men reboot, but she also
took the time to extract a group of young
mutants from Saigon.
To do it, she disguised herself as a US Army
Colonel - before she was forced to rely on
her fists and feet.
It's a heroic act, but when you notice that
Mystique has disguised herself as "Colonel
Sanders", the founder and mascot of Kentucky
Fried Chicken, it's clear she was still having
fun.
Those are the small details that comic book
movie fans probably missed, but which ones
have we left out?
Let us know in the comments, and be sure to
subscribe to our channel to watch more hidden
details videos like this one!
Click on the link and enjoy!